[Music]
no matter
where you are what your position always
try
to push the boundary push the boundary
even only one inch
she successfully steered her country
through the financial crisis
and is known as a tough reformer of
southeast asia's largest economy
indonesian finance minister srimalyani
forbes has repeatedly included you in
the list of the most powerful women in
the world
an economist a mother of three and
a role model how did trimuyani come to
power in a largely conservative society
how is she using her position to empower
women in indonesia
and what role can men play in the fight
for equality
let's find out
[Music]
thank you for joining our series marcus
era the women of
power you are a woman of power as
indonesia's first
era female finance minister how does it
feel to be
a pioneer the challenge for a woman in
any position especially if that position
is the
first time in the history then the woman
usually have
a more burden we call it double burden
or triple burden to prove it that you
were able to hold that position
with combatant with the ability to
deliver
the responsibility i think that is very
typical for many women usually the male
counterpart will not be asked that kind
of question it is
considered as natural for them to hold
their office
but for women you really have to prove
it isn't frustrating sometimes for you
how did you manage to to overcome these
obstacles
i'm fully aware that this is going to
happen because i come from my family
background in which my
my mother was also a pioneer
she was the first to take the phd degree
in education so she always said
the world is not fair for a woman as a
woman
you have to really like prove it that
you are smarter than others
i was prepared to face this kind of
situation
it's not frustrating it's more like even
the motivation
to show that we we deserve
we are able to do that
during her first tenure muyani tackled
corruption and managed to reduce
indonesia's public debt as a result of
these reforms by 2010
the country recorded its highest annual
economic growth since 1997
a success that hit the headlines
[Music]
in 2010 srimulyani moved to the u.s to
work at the world bank as its managing
director
she used her platform at the
international financial institution
to promote gender equality mulyani
returned to indonesia in 2016 for a
second term as finance minister
she continues to support women believing
that education is key in achieving
gender equality
when the parent have only one
opportunity they will pick the boys
first
to go to school rather than the girls
and that is really the challenge so
we try to use this budget uh especially
in designing the social protection
providing equal opportunity whether this
is education
girls across indonesia especially those
living in rural areas throughout its
many islands
can benefit from this support they
repeatedly confront hurdles in their
lives and have to swim
upstream usually girls they perform well
academically but then if you have in a
higher education there is a problem of
the dropout there is still a problem in
part of indonesia like the
child marriage because the girls
especially in a rural area
when you are in a late teenager they
were asked why you're not married yet
if they have education high enough they
will be told that
oh you are scaring boy because you are
not in the position that
the boy feel comfortable to have a woman
which is
smarter than you are and so on so these
are all
the social norm values you have to
perform according to the perception
of the other gender or the society which
is
restricting you you really have to take
much more deeper on the social
construction social value
sometimes cultural or even religious in
this case
you've maybe heard of the gender gap the
term describes disparities between men
and women in different areas for example
the lack of equal opportunities in
education or labor market
mulyani is convinced that clothing the
gender gap
can help reduce poverty a lot of studies
showing
that the gender gap is definitely not
only costly
personally for a woman but costly for
the economy
if we can reduce the gap potentially
economy can
have 12 trillion which is i think is
around 11 percent of the global gdp
this is not only a problem in indonesia
but a problem all over the world
so potentially if you really can
create an equal opportunity to be able
to participate
not only in domestic but also in the
economy
then it is a winning for the family
for that woman but also for the society
in indonesia it's still not common for
women to work
outside their home only around half of
all women are employed in paint jobs
the rate has been stalling nearly for
two decades
what's holding women in indonesia back
similar reason like elsewhere once a
woman has children
she is expected to do most of the work
of raising them
and too many mothers don't really have
another choice
how was it for you you managed both
raising children
and having a successful career how did
you manage it
it was hard suddenly it's hard first i
also have a husband just like my father
who he's very supportive he's not
intimidated
he's not feel inferior marrying a woman
which is maybe perceived as strong
my own experience when i have my first
daughter in the united states and i have
to finish my dissertation but we are
running out of money
my husband and my baby that is at that
time was one year's
daughter she went back with uh my
husband
and i lived alone in united states to
finish my dissertation so we have like
one year apart
that was not an easy time but the
juggling
is the most difficult part and you still
also
like any other human being you are not
blessed with
35 hours a day i mean you all only have
the same like others 24 hours a day so
yeah i was lucky enough i'm lucky enough
to have that
it's still difficult to change this
mindset that's why srimuyani is
encouraging men to take parental leave
something quite new for indonesia more
importantly to educate is actually the
counterpart the male part
i think the men and the boys they need
to know that
when you talk about gender equality is
not threatening
their position their role i usually use
this metaphor
if you are going to have a shoes you
don't want the other one is high heel
the other one is like
the flat shoes you are not going to like
walk comfortably
you really have to have the same level
so that the society can actually
walking and pursuing our objective
or dream together
[Music]
indonesia is reportedly the second most
dangerous country for women in the
asia-pacific region
one in three women has reportedly
suffered gender-based violence in their
lifetime
sexual violence street harassment
trafficking and domestic violence are
widespread
in some parts of the country there are
high rates of child marriage too
and there is still no law in the country
protecting girls from female genital
mutilation
although it's internationally recognized
as a violation of human rights
almost half of all women in indonesia
have undergone the dangerous practice
all these issues are taboo in society
but i'm sure that with a more education
information and more influencer who can
provide
understanding on this area that would be
address
all the activists the ngo is also doing
try to do that address this area an
additional challenge
is the growing religious conservatism in
the country
indonesia has the largest muslim
population in the world within the
muslim community
traditionalists have made their voices
heard and are expanding their influence
they use social media to spread their
patriarchal views
i think as a muslim myself reading the
quran
i feel like they are giving equal
opportunity for men and women but i also
have to admit
some of religious practices who try to
then take
this kind of version or interpretation
in a very strict
and limited way which is then being
used to then restraining or constraining
especially women in their role
in society or even to have an equal
opportunity and that is
quite an example that we see and that's
why it is still quite
a challenge for all of us
here in germany chancellor angela merkel
is
the first woman to surf in her office
both of you
are trey blazers i admire her
especially in terms of her leadership
the width
that she continues pushing and pursuing
a lot of policy which is important not
only for germany and the german
people but also globally for example
like
climate change do you think the next
generation of women leaders might have
it
easier than you did as pioneers
i think for the next leaders it will not
be easier
because first maybe we think that it's
gonna be easier because
the glass ceiling has been broken
but i think for the next generation they
are going to be constantly compared
with who break those class initially
and this is i mean like angela merkel is
just
for middle leaders so the butt is very
high
because they always like oh okay you
actually enjoying
the benefit of those then you should be
higher than her
and that is going to be a pressure for
any woman leader
that is following angela merkel
no matter where you are what your
position
always try to push the boundary
push the boundary even only one inch
because that is going to give
more room for many of girls
and women with you or even after you
a strong leader who is using her
powerful position to push
boundaries for women's interests
indonesia's finance minister srimuryani
is aware of challenges girls and women
have to overcome in her conservative
country
and she is convinced that gender
equality is easier to achieve
with men as partners what is your take
on this
how can more men become allies and
support women's rights for the benefit
of all
let us know what you think and make sure
to watch all the other episodes of our
series
[Music]